[Music]
carbonated water also known as sparkling
water or seltzer is made by dissolving
carbon dioxide in water and creating
carbonic acid in other words it's water
with
bubbles although researchers say that
this bubbly beverage is just as
hydrating as its flat counterpart some
myths still
persist
research has found a connection between
phosphoric acid from carbonated Cola
drinks and low mineral density in women
but Seltzer does not contain phosphoric
acid in a 2006 study found the link to
bad bones only with colus and not other
carbonated soft drinks including
[Music]
Seltzer this rumor is based on evidence
that Sugar sweeten carbonated drinks are
associated with kidney stone
information but there is no evidence to
suggest that Seltzer leads to kidney
stones in fact drinking more water
whether it be flat or sparkling is
recommended for people suffering from or
with a history of kidney
[Music]
stones Seltzer is slightly more acidic
than still water but not as acidic as
sodas or some juices so it is seen as a
safer alternative for your teeth one
study by the University of Birmingham
showed that flavored Seltzer is more
acidic than non-flavored and therefore
potentially corrosive but the most
damage to your enamel is seen with
beverages that are sugar sweetened and
carbonated like
soda there's no evidence to show that
Seltzer causes any damage to the stomach
or stomach acid in fact an Italian study
showed that drinking carbonated water
actually helped relieve indigestion and
constipation an issue that is associated
with carbonated water is the experience
of gas and burping for this reason
Selzer is not recommended for people
with acid reflux or irritable bowel
syndrome and carbonated water is
different than tonic water club soda and
mineral water which may contain sodium
vitamins or sweeteners so it's important
to read the
label